das ist wirklich ein bild das wir wohl
nie vergessen werden schlittenhunde
ziehen ihre schlitten nicht über eis
sondern durch wasser die realität des
klimawandels produzent bilder die sich
in unser gedächtnis einbrennen und das
wird wohl das bild dieses jahres sein
dass wahrscheinlich mit der geringsten
eisfläche die je von menschen am nordpol
beobachtet wurde und es wird in die
geschichtsbücher eingehen ein
rekordsommer bedient voraussichtlich in
der arktis links zum science infections
täglich faszinierende wissenschafts
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
manche haben es noch immer nicht
mitbekommen der klimawandel ist in
vollem gange um 3 bis 5 grad celsius
könnten die wintertemperaturen in dieser
region bis zur mitte des jahrhunderts an
steigen schon jetzt liegt die temperatur
dort deutlich über dem langjährigen
durchschnitt und zwar um knapp 3 grad
auf dem rest der erde wurde eine
erwärmung von ungefähr 1 grad
festgestellt der grund dafür dass sich
die arktis stärker als andere regionen
der erde erwärmt liegt fachleuten
zufolge an der sogenannten taktischen
verstärkung im polarmeer und dem
grönländischen eisschild gibt es immer
weniger fläche die von eis bedeckt ist
doch die eisfreien flächen auf land und
im meer reflektieren das sonnenlicht
sehr viel weniger sondern absorbieren
die energie stattdessen und genau das
sehen wir auf dem bild eigentlich ist ja
noch aus aber unter dem wasser es ist
bei einer expedition in den enkel flieht
vor ort im nordosten grünlands
entstanden bei der netzgeräte
eingesammelt worden sind die letzte
woche war dort so warm dass sich eine
schicht von schmelzwasser gebildet hatte
für diese region war das extrem wetter
mit temperaturen von bis zu 17 grad und
so erwärmt sich die region immer weiter
in der fachsprache und dieser effekt der
reflektivität als albedo bezeichnet
verstärkt wird dieser effekt durch ruß
und staub die bei waldbränden in
sibirien und kanada entstanden sind und
sich auf dem grönländischen eis ablagern
auch dies führt dazu dass das
sonnenlicht deutlich weniger reflektiert
wird und schon jetzt sind die folgen
deutlich lauter aktuellen studie der
unep hat sich die aktive meereseisfläche
in den letzten 40 jahren also seit 1909
und 70 um 40 prozent verringert und
dieses jahr würde es wahrscheinlich
wieder ein rekord weniger eis als 2012
der bisherige mindestes rekord in der
arktis klimamodelle prognostizieren dass
die arktis in den sommern ab den 2030er
jahren sogar eisfrei sein wird es ist
nicht mehr lange hin
das problem dabei laut berechnungen der
uno sind die eismassen der arktis zu
einem drittel verantwortlich für den
anstieg des globalen meeresspiegels
damit ist nicht das meereseis gemeint
sondern das eis das in der folge vom
festland über schmelzende gletscher ins
meer gelangt der temperaturanstieg in
der arktis könnte indirekt auch dazu
führen dass bei uns in europa aber auch
in nordamerika und russland extreme
kältewellen drohen denn die luftströmung
des sogenannten polar windes schwächt
sich durch die nachlassende eisbedeckung
des solar meeres phasenweise ab das kann
dazu führen dass kalte polare luftmassen
nach süden ziehen und im sommer wenn
immer mehr meeresfläche ausradiert
verdunstet immer mehr wasser in die
atmosphäre und regnet oder hagel dann
hier in gewaltigen mengen auf uns herab
geo storm wie realistisch faktencheck
kann man wetter klima manipulieren
anklicken anschauen und breaking lab
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran